Kevin and Ralph being two friends are
gonna be at your show John is a Babylon
virgin John and Cynthia you guys here
Johnson you know [ __ ] you then that read
me right now
although Cynthia did write if you can
convince Kevin to tell us about his
first [ __ ] experience I will buy you
a drink
did you tell a story recently to katie
morgan or something and said oh I blew
myself once I think that's what they
were talking about yeah when I was
younger I was way more nimble and [ __ ]
and I spent a couple days doing the you
know it's very very you gotta be careful
I was laying on my back on a bed and I
kept throwing my legs back over myself
and [ __ ] like that like a gymnast like I
was about to do a [ __ ] roll and stand
yeah but it was a rolling soft rule it
out make sure that like hey man I might
like it so I took a shot in the mouth
and I was like I don't know what I would
say after this and that was my own so
you know I was like I guess I'm kind of
at a girl's guy or something but I did
it you know you always think about like
if I could suck my dick I'd never leave
the house that's not true I know I'm
gonna be sorry that I'm asking this but
did you actually get your penis into
your mouth yeah yeah I didn't get like
full [ __ ] chefs I got that was like
Reed Richards in the [ __ ] like this
stuff it's just unbelievable and think
about now because now I would like I've
got this gut right here it'd be like
traversing [ __ ] Africa to get to my
dick but back then it wasn't as bad and
so you like let's say that you know
obviously this is not to scale right but
let's say this was the dick like I would
get to the head and all you need is the
head that's where all the action I was
always looking for neck action you know
so I got this right to the lips and
tongue and it was pretty pathetic if you
ever caught me it would have been like
[Music]
I was always terrified my mother would
walk in and be like oh my god but I did
it it was worth it yeah anyway back to
the news yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]